For those not familiar with this now popular
funny meme, the basic idea is to substitute
X with any perceived extremely powerful entity
that it would be futile to resist.
A somewhat recent example of this can be seen
when Ken Jennings, after losing to IBM’s
Watson on Jeopardy! in 2011, wrote underneath
his Final Jeopardy answer “I for one welcome
our new computer overlords.”
While you’ll often read that this was originally
a line spoken by actress Joan Collins in the
1977 film Empire of the Ants, this isn’t
correct.
Nowhere in this movie does any actor or actress
say that line.
(As I was reading conflicting accounts of
this from reputable sources, I confirmed it
is not spoken in this movie by watching the
whole amazing awful, yet surprisingly unintentionally
humorous horror film where “A heavenly paradise
becomes a hellish nightmare when a toxic spill
turns harmless ants into gigantic rampaging
monster insects.”
)
The closest thing to this statement anyone
says in the film is after Joan Collin’s
character Marilyn Fryser (a scammer trying
to sell worthless swampland as beach front
property to prospective clients) enters into
an enclosed space with the queen ant.
The queen then sprays her with a mind controlling
pheromones.
When Fryser went into the chamber, she was
screaming and trying to escape.
When she stepped out, she looks back at the
rest of her party, who are also seemingly
about to be put into the chamber, and says,
Don’t you see, we mustn’t’ disobey them.
We must take care of them and we must help
them.
While the line “I for one welcome…”
was never spoken in the film, when the authors
of this line came up with it, they were alluding
to Empire of the Ants’ plot of giant ants
enslaving humanity to work in sugar factories.
The first instance of this phrase can be found
in the 1994, season 5 episode of The Simpsons,
Deep Space Homer.
In this episode, Homer is selected by NASA
to be sent into space.
While in the space shuttle floating around
trying to eat potato chips before they “clog
the instrument panels”, Homer smashes into
the ant colony on board, breaking the glass
and releasing all the ants.
When one of the floating ants gets close to
the camera, it makes it look extremely large,
prompting Simpsons’ anchorman Kent Brockman
to think it is a giant ant.
He then states the following:
Ladies and gentlemen, uh, we’ve just lost
the picture, but what we’ve seen speaks
for itself.
The Corvair spacecraft has apparently been
taken over — ‘conquered’ if you will
— by a master race of giant space ants.
It’s difficult to tell from this vantage
point whether they will consume the captive
Earth men or merely enslave them.
One thing is for certain: there is no stopping
them.
The ants will soon be here.
And I for one welcome our new insect overlords.
I’d like to remind them that as a trusted
TV personality, I can be helpful in rounding
up others to toil in their underground sugar
caves.
In an interview, Ken Jennings stated about
the Super Computer Watson, “Watson has lots
in common with a top-ranked human Jeopardy!
player: It’s very smart, very fast, speaks
in an uneven monotone, and has never known
the touch
of a woman.”